Everybody, this is Dr. Colors. I just want to show you what a fairite core or a fairite bead is on your
electronic devices. So you've seen different electrical cords that have these little
things. What are they? They're called fairite cores or fairite beads. What they do are
electrical wires, as they reduce
stray electricity. Electricity from your house, affecting the cord, it reduces the radio frequency
electricity into the electronics. It can help save electronics. It can help with damaged
cords and just picking up stray electricity at your house. We have now begun to put these fairite
beads, fairite cores on all the bulb wires, both at the ends of the wire here, then up
near the bulb as well. So you'll see these on your bulb if we've already placed them. Otherwise,
I will send out these fairite beads, at least for the Attila Robin machines, because they're
three times the voltage has the true right. It's good to have these on there. You can buy
these on Amazon. You can get them in a hardware store. You can get them really anywhere and
snap them on. They un-stap and snap on right there. You have to use a little knife or a screwdriver
to unclip these and then they snap on and clip back into place. Pretty easy to put on, but
it'll help save electronics. It'll help give you cleaner frequencies through the right
machine, because you won't be picking up stray frequencies just from your electronics. You'll
get a better treatment with it, and you'll preserve your fuses and preserve your equipment.